Vous avez vu le voyage d’État en Chine la semaine dernière
et le G20 ?
Oh là là ! Pas vrai ?
Voici notre arrivée
pour la rencontre la plus importante entre dirigeants mondiaux en Chine.
Le conseiller en matière de sécurité nationale jurait comme un charretier
sur le tarmac.
Pas de tapis rouge.
Il est sorti par l'arrière de l'avion
avec les journalistes et tous les autres.
Et plus tard, pendant le G20,
voilà Obama.
(Rires)
Salut, George.
Salut, Norman.
On dirait qu'ils vont se bouffer le nez, pas vrai ?
Et ça a été le cas, pendant 90 minutes, ils ont parlé de la Syrie.
Poutine ne voulait parler que de ça.
C'est lui qui décide, de plus en plus.
Il est prêt à s'investir là-bas.
Il n'y a pas grande affinité ou confiance mutuelle
mais les Américains ne lui dictent pas ce qu'il a à faire.
Et quand les 20 dirigeants se sont réunis ?
On se dit qu'à ce moment-là,
les Américains font leur part du boulot.
Aïe.
(Rires)
Tout a l'air d'aller pour Xi Jinping.
Angela Merkel a, comme toujours,
cette expression sur le visage.
Mais Poutine est en train de donner des ordres à Erdogan
et Obama a l'air de se dire : « Que se passe-t-il là-bas ? »
Et le problème, c'est que ce n'est pas un monde de G20,
le problème c'est que
c'est un monde G-zéro dans lequel nous vivons.
C'est un monde où aucun pays individuel ni alliance
ne peut faire face aux exigences d'un leadership mondial.
Le G20 ne fonctionne pas,
le G7, et tous nos amis, tout ça, c'est de l'histoire ancienne.
Donc, la mondialisation se poursuit.
Biens, services, personnes et capitaux se déplacent au-delà des frontières
à une rapidité jamais vue,
mais ce n'est pas le cas de l'américanisation du monde.
Maintenant que j'ai démontré ça,
je veux parler de deux autres questions.
Je vais parler des implications de cet état de fait
pour le monde entier.
J'en ferai le tour.
Ensuite, je parlerai
de ce qu'on pense ici,
aux États-Unis et à New York.
Quelles implications, et pourquoi en sommes-nous là ?
Nous en sommes là
parce que nous, les États-Unis,
nous avons dépensé 2000 milliards de $ pour les guerres d'Irak et d'Afghanistan,
qui ont été des échecs.
Nous ne voulons plus faire ça.
Une grande part de nos classes moyennes et ouvrières
ont le sentiment que la mondialisation ne leur a pas profité,
alors elles n'y tiennent pas plus que ça.
Et nous avons eu une révolution énergétique
qui fait que nous n'avons plus besoin de l'OPEC ou du Moyen-Orient.
Nous produisons tout ça sur le sol américain.
Donc les Américains ne veulent plus être le shériff qui assure la sécurité du monde
ni être les architectes du commerce mondial.
Les Américains ne veulent même pas défendre leurs valeurs dans le monde.
Ensuite, on se tourne vers l'Europe.
Une alliance mondiale des plus importantes
a été la relation transatlantique.
Elle est à son plus faible niveau depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Et on a toutes les crises, les discussions sur Brexit,
l'évitement de politiques risquées entre Français et Russes,
Allemands et Turcs, Britanniques et Chinois.
Les Chinois veulent diriger
mais seulement dans le domaine économique.
Ils veulent que leurs valeurs, leurs principes et leur monnaie
fassent concurrence à ceux des États-Unis.
Et les Russes veulent plus de leadership.
On le voit en Ukraine,
dans les États baltes, au Moyen-Orient,
mais pas avec les Américains.
Ils veulent leur propres préférences et commandement.
Et voilà pourquoi nous en sommes là.
Alors, comment avancer dans ce contexte ?
Commençons par le plus facile :
le Moyen-Orient.
(Rires)
Bon, je n'ai pas tout mis,
mais vous voyez les grandes lignes.
Il y avait trois raisons
qui expliquaient la stabilité du Moyen-Orient.
Primo, il y avait une volonté des États-Unis et de leurs alliés
de fournir des moyens militaires pour assurer la sécurité.
Deuxio, on pouvait faire de l'argent facile en exploitant les ressources du sol
parce que le pétrole était cher.
Et tertio,
même quand les dirigeants étaient affreux, les populations étaient plutôt dociles.
Elles n'avaient ni les capacités, ni pour beaucoup l'envie,
de se soulever.
Je vous garantis que dans un monde G-zéro,
tous ces éléments sont de plus en plus absents
et on se retrouve donc avec des États en échec,
le terrorisme, les réfugiés et tout le reste.
Le Moyen-Orient tout entier s'effondre ?
Non, les Kurdes iront mieux, et aussi plus tard l'Irak, Israël et l'Iran.
Mais en gros, la situation n'est pas terrible.
Et lui, alors ?
Il joue un bon jeu avec de mauvaises cartes.
Il est certain que ses performances excèdent ses capacités.
Mais sur le long terme -- vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Mais sur le long terme,
si vous pensez que les Russes
ont été contrariés par les États-Unis et l'Europe postant l'OTAN à leur porte
malgré leur promesse,
et par l'UE qui marche sur leurs plates-bandes,
attendez de voir que les Chinois investissent des milliards de dollars
dans les pays autour de la Russie où ils croyaient être influents.
Les Chinois vont étendre leur domination, les Russes auront les miettes.
Dans un monde G-zéro, les dix prochaines années vont être tendues pour M. Poutine.
Mais, bon tout ne va pas mal, pas vrai ?
L'Asie a l'air bien plus en forme.
Il y a de vrais dirigeants en Asie
qui ont une grande stabilité politique.
Ils sont là pour durer.
Il y a M. Moodi, en Inde,
M. Abe, qui va probablement faire accepter la possibilité d'un troisième mandat
avec le parti démocrate-libéral japonais.
Il y a bien sûr Xi Jinping qui consolide son pouvoir considérable.
Il est le dirigeant le plus puissant en Chine
depuis Mao.
Voilà les trois plus grandes économies d'Asie.
Bon, il y aussi des problèmes en Asie,
comme les tensions autour de la Mer de Chine méridionale.
Kim Jong Un, dans les derniers jours,
vient de tester une autre arme nucléaire.
Mais les dirigeants d'Asie ne ressentent pas le besoin
de faire flotter leur drapeau,
de devenir xénophobes,
de permettre la montée
des tensions géopolitiques et transfrontalières.
Ils se concentrent sur la stabilité et la croissance économique à long terme.
C'est ce qu'ils font vraiment.
Venons-en à l'Europe.
L'Europe a l'air apeurée dans ce contexte.
Une grande partie des problèmes au Moyen-Orient
débarque littéralement sur les côtes d'Europe.
On assiste au Brexit et aux inquiétudes liées au populisme
dans tous les États européens.
Je vous garantis qu'à long terme,
dans un monde G-zéro,
on pensera que l'expansion européenne est allée trop loin.
L'Europe est allée jusqu'aux limites de la Russie et jusqu'au Moyen-Orient
et si le monde était vraiment de plus en plus plat et américanisé,
ça poserait moins de problèmes,
mais dans un monde G-zéro, ces pays au plus près de la Russie
et du Moyen-Orient
ont des capacités économiques différentes,
une stabilité sociale différente
et des systèmes politiques différents de l'Europe historique.
L'Europe pouvait vraiment s'étendre
au temps du G7,
mais dans un monde G-zéro, l'Europe rétrécira.
L'Europe historique autour de l'Allemagne, la France et les autres
sera toujours fonctionnelle, stable, riche et intégrée.
Mais la périphérie,
les pays comme la Grèce, la Turquie et d'autres,
n'auront pas bonne mine.
En Amérique du Sud, beaucoup de populisme
a mis à mal les économies.
Pendant longtemps, ces pays se sont opposés aux États-Unis.
Ils reviennent dans son giron.
On voit ça avec l'Argentine
et avec l'ouverture de Cuba.
On verra ça au Vénézuela quand Maduro sera défait.
On verra ça au Brésil après la mise en accusation de Rousseff
quand un nouveau président légitime aura enfin été élu là-bas.
Le seul pays qui va dans une autre direction
est le Mexique de l'impopulaire Président Peña Nieto.
Là-bas, il est possible qu'on assiste à une distanciation d'avec les États-Unis
dans les années à venir.
Cela dépend aussi beaucoup des élections américaines.
(Rires)
L'Afrique ?
On a pas mal entendu dire que la décennie de l'Afrique est arrivée.
Dans ce monde G-zéro, c'est une époque géniale
pour quelques pays africains
qui sont bien gouvernés et fortement urbanisés,
avec beaucoup de gens intelligents, une main d’œuvre qui se féminise
et un dynamisme commercial qui décolle.
Mais pour la plupart des pays africains,
ça va être plus dangereux,
avec des conditions climatiques extrêmes,
le radicalisme islamiste et le radicalisme chrétien,
une gouvernance de faible qualité,
des frontières impossibles à défendre, des migrations forcées.
Ces pays pourraient être rayés de la carte.
Alors on va voir se produire une réelle ségrégation
entre les gagnants et les perdants en Afrique.
Pour en revenir aux États-Unis...
Qu'est-ce que je pense de nous ?
Il y a beaucoup de gens contrariés,
pas ici à TEDx, je sais bien,
mais aux États-Unis, et grand Dieu,
après 15 mois de campagne, c'est compréhensible.
Je comprends ça.
Mais beaucoup de gens contrariés disent : « Washington ne marche pas,
on se méfie de l'establishment. On hait les médias. »
Même des mondialistes comme moi doivent faire face à ça.
Je pense que nous devons reconnaître,
mes amis campeurs,
que quand l'ours est à vos trousses,
dans le contexte mondial, il ne s'agit pas de courir plus vite que lui
mais seulement plus vite que les autres campeurs.
(Rires)
Je viens de vous parler
de ce qui arrive à nos amis campeurs.
De ce point de vue,
on s'en sort pas mal.
Beaucoup de gens disent :
« Adoptons le dollar et le marché immobilier new-yorkais.
Envoyons nos enfants dans des universités américaines. »
Nous avons des super voisins :
le Canada, le Mexique et deux grandes étendues d'eau.
Vous imaginez comme la Turquie aimerait avoir de tels voisins ?
Ce sont des voisins trop bien !
Le terrorisme est un problème aux États-Unis.
Nous ne le savons que trop bien ici, à New York.
Mais le problème est bien pire en Europe.
Et bien pire encore au Moyen-Orient
qu'en Europe.
Voici des facteurs importants.
Nous venons d'accepter 10 000 réfugiés syriens et nous nous en plaignons.
Et comment ça se fait ? Ils ne peuvent pas nager jusqu'ici.
Pas vrai ? Les Turcs adoreraient n'avoir que 10 000 réfugiés.
Et les Jordaniens, les Allemands, les Britanniques, pas vrai ?
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Voilà la réalité de la situation américaine.
Ça a l'air plutôt pas mal.
Voilà notre défi :
dans un monde G-zéro, il faut diriger
en étant un exemple.
Si nous ne voulons pas assurer la sécurité du monde
ou être les architectes du commerce mondial
ou promouvoir nos valeurs dans le monde,
et que nous ne ferons plus tout ça,
et que le XXIe siècle change,
alors nous devons incarner un exemple si persuasif
que les autres pays continueront à dire :
ils ne sont pas juste les plus rapides ;
même quand l'ours n'est pas là, ils ont une position enviable ;
suivons donc leur exemple.
Notre course électorale cette année n'est pas une très bonne façon
de diriger par l'exemple.
Hillary Clinton dit pouvoir revenir aux années 1990.
On peut toujours promouvoir nos valeurs dans le monde,
être les architectes du commerce mondial
et assurer la sécurité du monde.
Quant à Donald Trump, il veut revenir aux années 1930.
Son credo, c'est « Faites ce que je dis ou bien barrez-vous. »
Les deux candidats ignorent cette vérité fondamentale dans un monde G-zéro :
bien que les États-Unis ne soient pas en déclin,
il est, de fait, de plus en plus difficile
pour les Américains d'imposer leur volonté
ou d'avoir une grande influence
sur l'ordre mondial.
Sommes-nous prêts à être leaders en montrant l'exemple ?
Comment réparer cette situation
après le mois de novembre
et l'arrivée du prochain président ?
Soit nous avons une nouvelle crise qui nous oblige à agir,
comme une dépression économique,
une autre crise financière mondiale,
ou, Dieu nous en garde, un 11 septembre.
Soit, sans crise,
nous devrons accepter
que les délocalisations les inégalités, les difficultés
qui se multiplient aux États-Unis
sont urgentes en elles-mêmes
et doivent faire réagir nos dirigeants.
Nous avons ces voix.
Avec chacun de nos téléphones portables,
nous avons ces voix qui peuvent les faire changer.
Il y a aussi un troisième choix,
peut-être le plus probable :
nous ne ferons ni l'un ni l'autre
et dans quatre ans, je reviendrai ici
et je ferai exactement le même discours.
Merci. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)